hello these guys seem to know your work
hey get it they understand what a
celebrity shows up he'll make a car I'm
wearing a three layers yes to offset I
don't have you can see the guy in the
front row no he's wearing flip-flops yes
and I rented the conversations this
honey we're gonna go see Conan where are
my shower shoes at between my toes it's
a relaxed culture we're out here in Los
Angeles man I got really this is a talk
show baby
have some respect for it what are you
talking about it's that no look we got a
fake moon who cares
listen this Jimmy old chum yep
you seem like a peppy guy you seem like
a sweet guy but I do know you well
there's some rage in there yeah just got
mad at guys you joined Twitter this year
and I've been reading your tweets and a
lot of them are angry there's an angry
vibe to some of your tweets of course
I'm a comedian I'm filled with rage of
course all right let's take a look at
this one right here Oh what witness out
if I'm ever convicted of murder assume
it's because the store clerk called me
bro more than twice so that obviously
something that filled you with rage well
30 retweets that thing saying to some
people obviously I'm speaking for the
people to the people okay let's see the
next tweet mom just saw parents live
their parenting skills I tell you this
so you understand why I'm in prison for
double homicide a hashtag I did not do
it I kill anybody right apparently I
need to I'm gonna murder somebody it
sounds like yeah when you read those
tweets
I think it's an angry guy and then I
meet you and look at you such a chipper
huh again I've ever convenient filled
with that I do a community that's what
fuels us you know that no no I'm just
I'm filled with leprechauns and bunnies
inside things really leprechauns and
bunnies so your merger April
you